today I didn't study any Korean today
I'm just gonna talk a little bit about
language I like this shot here in the
bathroom we play golf
don't forget him down here for my wife's
birthday milestone birthday she's in the
next room so I'm doing it here in the
bathroom and I noticed that I show up on
the back mirror which makes me look a
little bit ridiculous which is good we
need to recognize that we are kind of
ridiculous little figures strutting
around around here thinking that were
very important language today in Canada
in the National Post there was an
article about a store in amber Quebec
right across from Ottawa where no feasts
Toronto says sent a message saying that
while the story's bombing role in the
staff is bilingual and the customers are
reading wrong they have an
english-language Facebook page and if
they don't translate it into French they
will be liable to financial and legal
sanctions which is completely ridiculous
but what's even almost more ridiculous
were the comments on the National Post
article by English Canadians who
basically were expressing I would say
scorn for Quebec Quebecers like
everybody is kind of identified with
this this action by the language zealots
and of course comments on a newspaper
article on the internet or anything on
the Internet is more he's not like
conversation amongst people whom you
know it's more like drive-by shootings
where people will say anything
completely stupid comments which leave
you with a very poor impression of the
group that those people represent but it
kind of reminds me of the situation in
Ukraine some of the comments I haven't
heard a lot but you know first of all
you have the the zealots no sooner have
they taken power or these nationalists
from the Western Ukraine and you know
they don't know where their next you
know they're gonna pay their government
employees the country's bankrupt and the
first thing I think of doing
is repealing a law that gave Russian and
other minority languages official status
in those regions of the country where
there were more than 10% of the
population are those people completely
stupid so then now we have all kinds of
problems in the Ukraine I'm not saying
that it was cause that the issues in
Crimea would cause by this but the
certainiy those actions didn't help the
situation Russian you know people
sometimes say well our language should
be a unifying factor and if we all you
know learn more languages we wouldn't go
to war well the you must live example
doesn't prove that they all spoke the
same language people in Northern Ireland
can't seem to get along and they speak
the same language Russian should be a
unifying factor in Ukraine they all
speak that language from what I can
gather but then of course some of the
comments you get like from Russians that
come on either on my youtube channel or
elsewhere on the internet trying to
prove scientifically you know some guy
Wasserman that you know Ukrainian is an
artificial language genetically they're
no different like first of all genetics
doesn't matter because Ukrainians nor
the Russians are probably in fact are
genetically more similar to Baltic
people southern Ukrainians probably the
Ukrainians and the Russians are very
similar it doesn't matter
that's national identity is not about
genetics is not about DNA it's about
history institutions self-identification
recognition all those kinds of things so
to have some guy talk about scientific
reasons why the Ukraine is not different
whether or not the Ukraine should ever
have separated from Russia I have no
opinion whether you know Crimea should
separate I have no opinion but genetics
and Jena and Ukrainian as an artificial
language or someone come out and say
well you know they speak Ukrainian when
they're speaking in public but then
privately they speak Russian well so
what so what it's more like the kinds of
comments around that that were on that
the National Post article it's really up
to them what they want to do
and and why is it so bad that they
separated or don't separate or whatever
I mean the checks in the slow back
separated they're as happy as can be the
various you have Republic's if they had
separated peacefully they'd be further
ahead today you know I'll go back is
separate they asked Canadians who are
heaping scorn of Quebec should Quebec
separate no well if you don't like them
so much maybe they should separate and
of course on an individual basis
Canadians English and French get along
fine but whenever they identify a group
yeah they have a separatist government I
don't think the majority of Quebecers
favor and the government going after
some little you know ladieswear store
that has an english-language Facebook
page of course they don't bond if Quebec
separated wouldn't matter yeah it's kind
of in the middle of a country but
Switzerland is in the middle of a EU and
people drive across it it doesn't matter
things that people get upset about then
they go to war over like the First World
War
people still writing books about what
caused the First World War because you
don't really know in retrospect what
people were fighting for and they died
by the millions so that's kind of where
I am today a bit sad that we see so much
stupidity and and language should be a
unifying force and really you know I
must say coming down to the states it's
always fun to travel wherever I travel
people are friendly when you're a
foreigner people are especially friendly
people like to get together eat talk and
join each other's company that's what
really matters not getting all excited
over things that you know really don't
matter I mean people get all getting
activity if the Austrians have to be in
the Balkans they had to force their way
and then the Serpent's bumped off the
heir-apparent so then they declared war
on Serbia it was a big deal for them to
be in the Balkans and four years later
they all voted the german-speaking
Austrians voted to join Germany so all
of a sudden that was the thing they
wanted to do you know Ukrainians
thirty years ago when the thought of
separating from the Soviet Union now
they're separate they like that
lots of wasted energy anyway that's my
video for today